how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
some quite interesting news about
possibly the most anticipated thing that
everybody is waiting for
with the marvel cinematic universe
wolverine in the mcu news
now it's hard to think of anybody else
besides hugh jackman playing wolverine
but since he's already stated that he's
done playing wolverine and maybe if the
mcu had started just a little bit sooner
he could have reprised the role
which is a truly depressing thought but
moving on he has said that he is no
longer going to be playing
wolverine so eventually somebody else
will have to step in the shoes and take
on the role of
wolverine and good luck to him because
that actor is going to be judged
severely and compared to hugh jackman's
wolverine which everybody pretty much
loves and although we don't know who the
actor that's going to be playing
wolverine is we do have
a little bit of information about what
wolverine could possibly be like when he
finally does make his mcu debut
so let's break it all down but first if
you don't know i'm giving away an iron
spider funko pop this week all you got
to do to enter
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below so today's report and
rumor is coming from daniel richmond
about
wolverine when he finally enters the mcu
this report says that when wolverine
finally does enter the mcu he is going
to be positioned as more of
an anti-hero instead of a typical hero
instead of being a black and white
character he's going to be more of a
gray area character
now we're assuming the new plan for this
new wolverine when he comes to the mcu
is going to be to somehow differentiate
him from
hugh jackman's wolverine everybody at
marvel studios knows that
everybody loved hugh jackman and to
simply replace him with the same type of
character
is not the smartest move they know that
if you're going to bring in a new
wolverine he's going to have to be
different
so taking wolverine and instead of
making him a hero make him more of an
anti-hero actually makes a lot of sense
for marvel to do
now with making wolverine more of an
anti-hero than a hero there is a good
possibility that marvel studios may
just be trying to make a very comic
accurate version of wolverine
an anti-hero doesn't necessarily mean an
evil person or somebody who wants to do
bad it could simply mean that they're
not the typical hero
and wolverine isn't your typical hero he
smokes has many relationships he's very
aggressive he curses
a lot and he's basically an animal hence
the wolverine
he also kills and he kills on purpose
there are times in the comics where he
kills and he probably shouldn't he
probably should have restrained himself
a bit
he has a basic instinct to kill and in
some ways
is kind of a homicidal maniac but
nonetheless he usually does kill
to do good he may be unconventional but
he is still
a hero it just may not be in typical
fashion hence anti-hero
but what this means is that when the
x-men finally do enter the mcu and we
actually have an x-men team-up film
wolverine may not be a part of that team
we already know that the x-men and
mutants are going to be introduced
throughout phase 4
5 and 6 before we actually get an x-men
movie from what we know it'll basically
be like the avengers setup we get
introduced to tony stark
thor captain america and others and then
they finally come together to form a
team
the plan for the x-men is apparently the
same introduce them individually then
have them come together
forming the x-men but if wolverine is
going to be an anti-hero he may not join
the team originally
in fact it'll probably take a world
threatening villain for him to
eventually come help
now just because they might make
wolverine an anti-hero doesn't mean we
aren't going to get the typical traits
of wolverine that we love
wolverine does have a very dark path
covered in death and destruction
and sometimes he can go into a mindless
fury however
he does have a sense of justice and he
does whatever he can to protect his
loved ones
his fellow mutants and x-men members and
he does defend the innocent
he may not be the perfect hero but in
our book he's definitely the perfect
anti-hero
so be sure to subscribe to my channel so
you can stay up to date on anything that
we hear about marvel's wolverine
coming to the mcu and in the meantime if
this rumor ends up being true what do
you think about this would you be okay
with this story arc for wolverine
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below don't forget to
give the video a like you can follow me
on instagram and twitter for live
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you